el grupo talibán tomo afganistán pero
enfrenta varios desafíos económicos sus
principales ingresos provienen del
tráfico de drogas desde la invasión
estadounidense el cultivo de opiáceos
aumento en la nación el 84% de la
producción mundial procede de afganistán
según la oficina de la onu contra la
droga y el delito
a partir de 2014 los talibanes se
apoderaron cada vez más del campo de
este modo pudieron hacerse con el
control de los laboratorios allí
comienzan a tener acceso a la parte más
lucrativa del comercio de drogas
además los fundamentalistas se basan en
otras actividades delictivas para su
financiación como la explotación de
minerales nuestros el grupo talibán
también impone peajes ilegales en las
carreteras y comen puestos ilegales a
las empresas por hacer negocios por
último recibe apoyo financiero del
extranjero de partidos políticos
paquistaníes y de ricos donantes
privados de los países del golfo con
todo ello según naciones unidas los
talibanes tienen un ingreso anual de
entre 300 y 1.600 millones de dólares
pero será este dinero suficiente para
gobernar el país la ayuda internacional
a la nación supone el 42 por ciento del
pib fue congelada y las reservas del
banco central afgano unos 9.000 millones
de dólares depositados en eeuu también
han sido bloqueados
con unos pocos cientos de millones de
dólares los talibanes dirigieron una
exitosa guerra de guerrillas ahora deben
crear un estado que funcione se requiere
un tipo de recursos muy diferentes
el talibán ahora tiene que gobernar un
país empobrecido más del 47% de la
población vivía por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza en 2020 el gobernador
interino del banco de afganistán predijo
la desvalorización de la moneda el
aumento de la inflación y de los precios
con un 11 7 por ciento de la población
afgana desempleada y dependiente de las
ayudas internacionales antes del régimen
talibán los civiles serán nuevamente los
más golpeados